JESSE WATTERS, JUAN WILLIAMS,
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE."
SOMEONE IS HAVING A GOOD WEEK
AND IT'S ONLY MONDAY.
>> THERE WAS NO COLLUSION WITH
RUSSIA.
THERE WAS NO OBSTRUCTION, NONE
WHATSOEVER.
AND IT WAS A COMPLETE AND TOTAL
EXONERATION.
THIS WAS AN ILLEGAL TAKEDOWN
THAT FAILED.
AND HOPEFULLY SOMEBODY IS GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT THE OTHER SIDE.
>> Greg: THANK GOD, THE MEDIA
SAW THIS COMING.
CAN I HEAR A "IF TRUE."
>> IF TRUE, FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS HAVE EVIDENCED THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
COMMITTED A SERIOUS CRIME AND
POTENTIALLY IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> CONFIRMING PART OF THE STILL
DO DOSSIER.
>> COULD TIP THE ELECTION IN
DONALD TRUMP'S FAVOR.
IF THAT IS TRUE, IT'S HIDDEN
ENCUMBRANCE OF THE BIG DEAL.
>> HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THE MAN
AFFORD ALLEGATIONS?
>> THERE WAS NO COLLUSION ON HIS
PART?
>> THAT MAY BE THE MOST
SUSPICIOUS DENIAL WE'VE HEARD.
>> I THINK THEY ARE SHOCKED THAT
THE NOOSE IS TIGHTENING.
>> Greg: IF TRUE.
ABOUT COLLUSION.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT HAS INSISTED
FROM THE START THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION.
>> THIS VINDICATES THE
PRESIDENT.
>> SMOKE ABOUT RUSSIAN COLLUSION
BUT NO FIRE.
>> 500 SEARCH WARRANTS.
FOUND NO EVIDENCE OF CONSPIRACY
BY DONALD TRUMP OR ANYONE AROUND
HIM.
IT'S A HUGE DEAL AND A HUGE WON
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: 911, I WOULD LIKE TO
REPORT A DEATH.
IT'S THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
FINALLY CHOKING ON THEIR OWN
LIVES.
THAT SHOULD BE A VICTORY LAP BUT
IF I WAS THE PRESIDENT I WOULD
BE TICKED OFF.
DESPITE THE RELIEF INDICATION
BRINGS, IT WON'T UNDO THE HARM
FALL CRAP.
IF TRUE, SOURCES SAY, JUMPED --
JUNK TERMS.
WE HAD TO PLAY ALONG BECAUSE
SKEPTICISM WAS PORTRAYED BY THE
MEDIA AS AIDING TRUMP.
AT CNN, THEY WONDER, HAS A
RUSSIA COVERAGE HELPED OR HURT?
IT'S LIKE A SLOPPY DRUNK
WONDERING IF THERE DRINKING HURT
THEIR REPUTATION.
ESPECIALLY WHEN REPORTERS
PRONOUNCE THE STORY WORSE THAN
WATERGATE.
>> WHAT WE ARE WATCHING THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY IS WORSE THAN
WATERGATE.
>> I'VE SAID BEFORE THAT WHAT WE
ARE SEEING IS WORSE THAN
WATERGATE BECAUSE IN WATERGATE,
THE SYSTEM WORKED.
>> Greg: THE ONLY THING WORSE
THAN WATERGATE WASN'T THERE LIE
THAT IT WAS WORSE THAN
WATERGATE.
IT WASN'T COMMENTATORS LIKE US
WHO PUSH THIS BUT SO-CALLED
ANALYSTS REPORTERS AND EXPERTS.
WHEN TRUMP SAID FAKE NEWS WAS
THE END OF YEAR PEOPLE, BUT IF
THEY PROVE HIM RIGHT.
IT WAS ABOUT YOU.
DIVIDING US, CONFLICT AS A
BUSINESS MODEL.
SMOLLETT, KAVANAUGH, COVINGTON.
COLLUSION, THEY HIT SKEET COMING
IN THE MEDIA NEVER LEARNS.
THE STEELE DOSSIER WAS FAKED,
THE LEAKS FAKED, FISA SYSTEM
ABUSED.
IT IS NOT TRUMP THAT RUSSIA'S
NAME TO.
IT'S A BUNCH OF USEFUL IDIOTS
CALLED THE PRESS.
JESSE, I'M GOING TO HAND OVER
THE REST OF THE SHOW TO YOU AND
I'M GOING TO THE BAR TO
CELEBRATE.
>> Jesse: I WILL BE RIGHT
THERE WITH YOU.
LAST NIGHT FELT LIKE ELECTION
NIGHT ALL OVER AGAIN.
NO COLLUSION, NO OBSTRUCTION.
JUAN, YOU DON'T HAVE TO SAY
ANYTHING.
I ACCEPT YOUR APOLOGY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: I SHOULD BRING YOU
PARTY HATS.
>> Greg: I WOULD WEAR IT.
>> Jesse: MAY BE A CAKE AND
PUTIN CAN JUMP OUT OF IT.
>> Juan: THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> Jesse: KNOCKOUT PUNCH TO
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE EVER GOING
TO RECOVER.
THEIR CREDIBILITY IS SHOT.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WILL NEVER
TAKE THEM SERIOUSLY AGAIN.
THEY BOOKED THEIR SHOWS FULL OF
FOOLS.
A ROSTER OF FOOLS.
THEY NEED TO LET THEIR CONTRACTS
EXPIRE AND PUT THEM OUT TO
PASTURE.
IT WAS A BUNCH WHO CRIED WOLF.
THERE'S A BIG SHIFT IN THE
MEDIA.
CNN, MSNBC -- THEY DUG THEIR OWN
GRAVES.
THEIR RATINGS ARE GOING TO
SOFTEN AND FOX NEWS RATINGS WILL
TAKE A POP AND WE HAVE THE STORY
RIGHT FROM THE JUMP.
IT WASN'T JUST OPINION PEOPLE.
THE HARD NEWS SITE.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE, BRET BAIER,
JOHN ROBERTS.
WE WERE THE ONLY ONES WHO FOLLOW
THE FISA ABUSE, THE DOSSIER,
PETER STRZOK AND ALL THOSE TEXT
MESSAGES.
WE FOLLOWED THE TRUTH AND WE
WERE SUSPICIOUS AND WE WERE
PROVEN RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT, AS YOU SAID
CALLED THE MEDIA FAKE NEWS
BECAUSE THEY GAVE AID AND
COMFORT TO THE ENEMY.
IT WASN'T DONALD TRUMP WHO WAS
THE TRAITOR.
THE TRADERS WERE INSIDE OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HS
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HL
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HO
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HE
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HD
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HB
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HC
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HK
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HH
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HE
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HL
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HS
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HT
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HO
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HY
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HA
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HS
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HD
GOVERNMENT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN HY
THANKS, DEMOCRATS.
YOU BASICALLY MADE RUSSIA LOOK
STRONGER AND DIVIDED THE COUNTR
COUNTRY.
44% SAY THAT TRUMP CAMPAIGN
COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA.
52% THINK TRUMP TRIED TO
INTERFERE WITH THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
FLAT OUT NOT TRUE.
IF YOU CRITICIZE THE MEDIA AND
SO THEY WERE FAKE NEWS, THEY
SENT OH, MY GOSH, YOU'RE
ATTACKING THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
YOU'RE ATTACKING THE FREEDOM OF
THE PRESS.
GREG, PERMISSION TO MAKE AN
ANALOGY.
>> Greg: SURE.
>> Jesse: THE MEDIA IS THE
DOSSIER.
THE MEDIA IS FAKE SMEARS BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AND SO INSTEAD
OF DOING AN AUTOPSY ON
THEMSELVES, THEY ARE SAYING
TRUMP HAS SHOWED LITTLE INTEREST
IN HEALING OUR NATIONAL UNITY.
>> Greg: THEY ARE PIVOTING.
MARTHA, WILL THE MEDIA EVER
REFLECT ON THESE MISTAKES THEY
ARE MAKING AND FOLLOW OUR LEAD
TO AN EXAMPLE AS OBJECTIVE?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Martha: FROM WHAT WE'VE
SEEN SO FAR, THERE DOESN'T SEEM
TO BE MUCH CAPITULATION, MUCH
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT WHAT JUST
HAPPENED.
WHAT THEY HAVE JUST WITNESSED.
THEY'VE IMMEDIATELY SPENT MOST
OF THE DAY -- I WAS WATCHING
OTHER CHANNELS IN MY OFFICE
THROUGHOUT THE DAY, MOST OF IT
ON THIS LITTLE OPENING FOR
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
THIS POTENTIAL THAT MAY BE THERE
IS SOME AVENUE FOR RECOVERY THAT
PERHAPS THERE WAS OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
THE THING THAT STRIKES ME IS IF
ANYONE THINKS THAT THE NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL RELEASE THIS
SUMMARY WITHOUT A VERY CLEAR
FEELING THAT IT ACCURATELY
REFLECTED WHAT WAS IN THE LARGER
REPORT THAT THEY ARE ALL
SCREAMING FOR FULL DISCLOSURE ON
AND I THINK WE ALL WANT TO SEE
IT.
OF COURSE AND WANT TO SEE IT.
I THINK THEY MAY TURN OUT TO BE
SADLY MISTAKEN.
>> Greg: I LOVE WATCHING THEM
SHOVE BRIAN STELTER THROUGH THAT
SMALL HOLE OF OBSTRUCTION.
ALL RIGHT, JUAN.
I KNOW IT'S HARD FOR YOU.
FIRST YOU DEFEAT ISIS ON FRIDAY,
COLLUSION GONE, MICHAEL
AVENATTI'S IN PRISON.
IT'S GOT TO KILL YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
IT'S LIKE THEY HAVE BUILT THE
WALL.
THE CHINESE DEAL IS DONE.
GET OUT OF HERE.
>> Greg: THAT'S TOMORROW.
>> Juan: IT IS GOOD NEWS.
FIRST OF ALL, I THINK IT'S GOOD
NEWS THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS NOT
FOUND TO HAVE CONSPIRED IN THE
WAY.
IT'S GOOD NEWS THAT ROBERT
MUELLER WAS ABLE TO CONDUCT A
NONPARTISAN PROBE AND COME TO
CONCLUSIONS THAT I THINK MOST OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN TRUST.
I THINK THE BAD NEWS ON THAT
FRONT IS HE CONFIRMED RUSSIA
INTERFERED IN THE 2016 ELECTION
TO HELP DONALD TRUMP AND THAT
FROM WHAT WE KNOW, TRUMP, YOU
KNOW, WELL, IF THAT'S HAPPENING,
HE DIDN'T TELL THE FBI.
A KIND OF WELCOMED IT.
NONE OF THE PEOPLE DIRECTLY
AROUND TEN WAS FOUND TO BE IN
CONSPIRACY WITH THE RUSSIANS.
>> Martha: THE FBI DIDN'T TELL
HIM THEY KNEW THAT WAS
HAPPENING.
>> Juan: THEY SUSPECTED IT.
>> Martha: THEY KEPT HIM FROM
KNOWING THAT SO HOW WOULD HE
HAVE DONE ANYTHING TO STOP IT?
>> Juan: HE COULD'VE
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT HE HAD
MEETINGS HERE AT TRUMP TOWER.
HIS SON IS HAVING MEETINGS WITH
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS.
HE THEN GOES ON -- HE SAYS --
>> Jesse: THE WHOLE MEETING
LOOKS LIKE A SET UP AT THIS
POINT.
>> Juan: HE WELCOMED RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS INTO HIS CAMPAIGN
OFFICE AND THEN SECONDLY HE
STANDING THERE NEXT TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND SAYS AMERICAN
INTELLIGENCE HAS HAD RUSSIA
INTERFERED.
I BELIEVE YOU, NOT MY
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS.
OR HOW ABOUT --
>> Martha: THAT WAS NOT A
GREAT MOMENTS.
>> Juan: IN THE BUSINESS ABOUT
I WASN'T DOING ANY BUSINESS WITH
RUSSIA DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW THAT'S NOT
TRUE.
>> Greg: WE KNOW THAT BUT I
WANT TO BRING DAMIEN.
DANA, THESE EXPERTS HAVE SO MUCH
EGG ON THEIR FACE, THEY COULD
OPEN A DENNY'S.
BUT AS JESSE SAID, THEY WILL BE
INVITED ON SHOWS TO PONTIFICATE
BECAUSE THEY EXPRESS THE PERFECT
ANTI-TRUMP SENTIMENT SO YOU WILL
STILL SEE DAVID FROMM AND BILL
KRISTOL.
>> Dana: THE CONTORTIONS WILL
BE INTERESTING TO WATCH OVER THE
NEXT BIT.
STILL COULD BE TRUE, TO MARTHA'S
POINT.
IF WE GET THAT DOCUMENT, IT WILL
BE INTERESTING TO ME TO SAY,
MEMBER AT AFTER THE 2016
ELECTION, REPORTERS WENT ON THE
ROAD TO FIGURE OUT HOW DID WE
GET IT WRONG AND HOW DID WE MISS
IT?
NOW BOOKS HAVE BEEN WRITTEN
ABOUT IT, HOW DID THEY      THEM
ABOUT IT, HOW DID THEY      THED
ABOUT IT, HOW DID THEY      THEU
ABOUT IT, HOW DID THEY      THEM
ABOUT IT, HOW DID THEY      THEI
ABOUT IT, HOW DID THEY      THES
IT?
FROM A PERSONAL ANECDOTE, GOING
BACK TO THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
OF THE VALERIE PLAME ISSUE WITH
KARL ROVE, HE KNEW THAT HE WAS
GOING TO BE -- NOT GOING TO BE
INDICTED BUT HE WASN'T ALLOWED
TO SAY ANYTHING.
THE STRESS AND THE AGONY WHAT
YOU PUT PEOPLE THROUGH WITH
SPECIAL PROSECUTORS.
>> Juan: I HOPE WE AGREE THAT
THE REPORT SHOULD BE RELEASED
BECAUSE I THINK REPUBLICANS AND